nearly 30 000 people were selected for
the study between February 2020 and
April 2021. they were selected from a
bone marrow donor database the study
published in nature science journal on
Wednesday found that those who
contracted covid-19 and didn't get sick
may have a mutated Gene that assists the
immune system during early infections
researchers discovered individuals with
a mutated human leukocyte antigen Gene
are more than twice as likely to not get
sick from the virus and those who had
two copies of the gene were more than
eight times more likely to remain
asymptomatic however the gene variant
does not stop the virus from entering
the body but it prevents people from
developing cold and flu-like symptoms
Colin furnace and infection control
epidemiologist says this proves that
asymptomatic people can indeed still
spread the covid-19 virus but it will
help for medical advancement we know
that some people seem to get coveted
easily and some people don't we know
that there's got to be a genetic thing
but we've all been focused on what are
the predictors of severe disease imagine
we had a diagnostic test that would say
you could get coveted bad or you will
never get coveted bad that would be
amazing furnace adds asymptomatic
individuals aren't invulnerable like
Superman in fact they cause a huge risk
to those around them he hopes that these
findings pave the way for future
diagnostic testing and therapeutic
advancements Elizabeth ogallis Global
News Montreal